(Casting)
Guys, having sick aim in CS:GO is one thing, now having sick aim while controlling the recoil of your fully-automatic weapon
while moving the mouse laterally. well, it's a completely different thing.
That’s right guys, this week we're doing the Best Of spray transfers.
No, not those sprays.
These sprays.
(Casting)
Guys, I don't need to tell you. Transferring your spray from one target to another, is no small feat.
I mean, you can't just hold down the left mouse button and pray like I do.
"Replay, sends every following shot to the same location."
You need to know the spray pattern of your weapon intimately.
(Casting)
"No way."
Well guys, those were some sick spray transfers, but they were all plays when the enemy was out in the open.
In the direct visual range of the player.
Now, it’s another thing entirely when you have to rely on your instincts in the middle of a transfer to tell you where the next target might be.
"Ahhh!"
"Argh!"
We're going to call this next section: the Best Of Multi-Angle Spray Transfers.
(Casting)
"Merry Christmas you filthy animal."
"You are already dead."
"What!?"
(Casting)
Well guys, that’s all we got for you on Best of this week.
Now, if you do enjoy these kinds of videos, stay tuned because next week we’re dropping the Top 10 shotgun kills for you.
"You're off the f***ing chain!"
Now, until then go ahead and transfer your mouse spray from the subscribe button over to the notification bell.
So you know whenever we publish another CS:GO video, and I'll see you next week.